i was talking with a navajo singer in
northern arizona
and this was years ago i was traveling
through the area with my friend and we
were looking for permission so he went
to his hogan
and and we brought groceries and sacks a
flower he invited us in and we sat and
talked for a while
translating through his his uh his adult
grandson
and and the singer asked if
if i had any questions i could ask
anything i wanted
and i said how did your people come
to be in this place how did the dna
arrive
in northern arizona and he said
we came from the ground and i knew this
this story from navajo cosmology that
that the people
emerged from underground and that's how
they arrived
in this in this desert um and
and so i pressed him on it and he said
no there there was
there was no migration we didn't arrive
from somewhere else we came from the
ground
and i think i was being tone deaf at
this point but i
i was trying to get to another point i
was saying well the
the dna language your language is here
in arizona
and it's also in the arctic in the yukon
territory in alaska
and it's also in siberia so there's this
arc
out of asia into the americas and he
said
no we came from the ground
and i looked down at the red moen copy
hard pack
underneath his hogan and i thought
they came from the ground of course
this is part of so many of the stories
that come out of north america out of
the native american tradition
of going from one world to the next
arriving in a new world for the navajo
there are the monster slayer stories
where
two twins are sent out to uh
to kill the um the monsters that
occupied the world
and make it safe for people for the
klinkit and
haida of the far northwest coast the
first people arrived in a clam shell
that was was sealed closed and it washed
up
on a beach and trickster god raven
showed up and opened up the clam shell
and let the first people out
for the hopi the arrival into this world
was uh the last world was flooding and
they crawled through a hole which turned
out to be a hole in the ground into this
world
and the water rose and sent them up to
here
there are so many stories about arrival
and transformation
that i i think it must have been a big
thing getting here
threading the eye of a needle a journey
was involved
a migration not from some other land or
continent
but from the ground from another world
which to me means a long
long time ago an arrival that people are
still talking about
and it was probably different for
everyone